in the last few videos we were studying
our watch factory ABC
watch Factory and based on some data
knowing what our fixed costs are our
labor units our variable costs our total
costs and then our total output and that
would be for different amounts of labor
we were able to calculate marginal
product of labor marginal cost average
variable cost average fixed cost and
average total cost what we're going to
do in this video is start to explore how
these various calculations will change
or and eventually how these curves will
change based on changes in cost and
productivity so let's say our rent has
gone up by two thousand dollars a month
and we have to pay that extra rent
regardless of what our output is so
what's what is that going to do to
marginal product of labor marginal cost
average variable cost average fixed cost
and average total cost pause this video
and think about what's going to happen
before we actually model it in this
spreadsheet by raising our fixed costs
our monthly fixed costs so we are going
to go from five thousand dollars a month
of fixed cost to seven thousand dollars
a month a fixed cost so it's going to be
seven thousand but we're not done yet we
want to scroll all the way down and so
what changed from what I had before well
if you were paying close attention your
marginal product of labor hasn't changed
your marginal cost haven't hasn't
changed your average variable cost
hasn't changed your average fixed and
average total costs did change and that
should hopefully make intuitive sense if
you look at the formulas for these
things for example the marginal product
of labor you would see that it involves
total output and the labor units it
doesn't involve the fixed cost at all so
if the fixed cost change you wouldn't
expect our marginal product of labor to
change when you look at marginal cost
you are involving total cost and you say
hey is it fixed cost part of total costs
but remember fixed costs is the seven
thousand dollars as part of the 13,000
and it's part of this
9,000 right over here so when you take
the 13,000 minus the 9000 which we do in
the numerator right over here we're
doing our change in total costs over our
change in output those 7 to $7000 cancel
out the fixed cost cancel out and so
your marginal cost is not dependent on
your fixed cost similarly your variable
cost is separate
you can view in a lot of ways from your
fixed costs so your average variable
costs aren't going to be affected by
fixed cost and of course you would
expect your average fixed costs to to
change because that is directly derived
from your fixed costs and your output
and then average total costs are also
derived from total costs it's not a
change between total costs and that
total cost has the fixed cost in it so
you might be asking yourself well what
would change your marginal product of
labor your marginal cost your average
variable cost or your average total
costs well think about a change in labor
productivity let's say that each person
there's some there's some magical new
device that allow the new process that
allows them to be a little bit more
productive well then one person instead
of producing 10 let's say they now
produce 11 and let's say two people is
not instead of 25 can now produce 27
let's say and three people instead of
forty-five can now produce 47 and now
four people and I'm making these numbers
up they cannot produce 59 let me say
that this is 66 and then let's say that
this is 72 and so notice that did change
our marginal product of labor and once
again marginal product of labor is based
on the difference in total output as we
have a difference in our labor units and
that change in productivity it might be
more pronounced than the way I just
happen to pick the numbers it was more
pronounced when you have fewer people
and then it got more diminished as you
had more and more people but when you
had that change in productivity you
might have noticed that that changed our
marginal cost and that changed our
average
variable costs because once again your
marginal costs if we look at it right
over here it is calculated by looking at
your change in total cost divided by
your change in total output and when we
had this productivity improvement our
change in total output improved now
there could be a situation where you
have a productivity improvement but the
change in total output from one person
to the next
might not change so it's not always
going to change either the marginal
product of labor or the marginal cost
but changes in productivity will often
change those two things and similarly if
you look at your average variable cost
it is based on your variable cost in
your output when you have this
productivity improvement that's going to
improve your output for any given amount
of a variable cost and so that's going
to have an effect on your average
variable cost and then your average
total cost is of course based in part on
your total variable cost which is driven
by that productivity improvement
similarly you could have changes in
variable cost let's say all of the
people who work at your factory have
gotten together and said we want to
raise and you give in and you you give a
raise well now instead of $2,000 per
worker it's going to cost $2,200 per
worker you gave a 10% raise per month
and so let me get that all the way down
and notice the things that you would
have expected to change did change your
marginal product of labor didn't change
because marginal product of labor is not
driven by cost it only looks at the
labor units and the total output but
your marginal cost did change even
though our output for every incremental
person did not change because the
underlying cost of the people changed
similarly the average variable cost you
would of course expect it to change
because our variable costs all went up
by 10% your average fixed cost isn't
going to be affected because we changed
the variable cost not the fixed and the
total costs were of course affected
because the average variable costs were
affected